speaking of which were there times where
you thought that the film was not going
to be made where it just was too
daunting or too emotional for you or
finances got out of control and what
happened so many times
you're just
taking odd jobs to try you know as a
filmmaker it's like taking out jobs not
understanding
what the real process is you know why
isn't someone
coming out of the woodwork all the phone
starts ringing you know it's just part
of
um
the process that i went through and
you know
i'm kind of glad there was a couple
times that i had to step away and the
project didn't go anywhere it's like a
year
and i'm kind of glad it did because i
grew more i think
as not only a person but just really
understanding that
um
you know i had to figure out a way
to remake it and and
put it into a story format and i put
myself more into it and that's i always
try to keep away from that because i was
like oh i'm a i'm the filmmaker i've got
to do it for everyone else and then i
realize
it wouldn't do anything without me and
so i put myself back into it as
as taking the drive away and giving it
to the editor letting go
but i was
present to just say i'm gonna just
keep the faith on that thing and it came
back even better and it was a process
that i'm glad it sat on the shelf for a
while because it helped me understand
that it was
it's gonna be done
and
it wasn't about the distribution you
know you come to all of these thoughts
that you're just doing it as
a filmmaker as someone that wants to
help other people
so there was no real funding behind it
you said some of these groups would foot
the bill for an airplane ticket or
something but it was really a piecemeal
type i i put some um i created um a
structure with an llc i went to some
family members
gave some
blood do some robert rodriguez whatever
hey i'll do this if you do that medical
test yeah i did i did whatever i could i
read that book too before i got into it
i thought it was great you know i did
whatever i could i
owed family i didn't know family i went
to work i mean i sold a
a business that i had for a while and i
put everything in behind it
and i saved up enough money from my last
job now to to to do the screenings
and
you know
here i am with you so
it i never i felt like i couldn't give
up on it and i still feel that way you
know i still feel like
you know from talking to
people out in the street yesterday that
you know it's just
the labor of love that i have for it
it's
and i have other film projects that i've
been sitting on for like five years that
i've wrote and
people say what happened to that script
let's do that that's an action drama
it's so fun let's come on we'll get the
actors we'll do this and you know i want
to do that but i haven't
i haven't found a home for this film yet
and
to get as much awareness as possible and
i think i think it's around the corner
i feel it and it might go online for
free or whatever it's going to do but it
will do something
or it could be coming coming ongoing and
with a transmedia angle to it and other
people adding their own stories i mean
i'm sure there's been an emotional
response that you've received even from
the few screenings that you've done we
have we feel we've got some positive
reviews we've got some negative reviews
you know
and that's all good stuff because people
are talking
and dialogue and what's right and you
know i was talking to a journalist who
said she grew up in a feminist days and
then she explained all her part in
divorce and all those things and when
she came out of the movie she was like
it's a good piece of work and that made
me feel good
and you know i think um
you said something like
you know there was a lot of emails that
just
kind of woke us up you know people were
telling us we couldn't go international
with this project but we got emails from
spain from germany
from australia
when is this movie coming out people
that were supporting and um
donating five dollars for a cup of
coffee you know
just
help
so